streaming or we live streaming is that
what's happening the live stream no
we're doing oh I didn't know that
that's exciting I've never done that
haha alright I guess I'll just stay
quiet so welcome to The Comedy Store
podcast how many people who listen to
The Comedy Store podcast alright yeah
sorry Rick's not here he has a hatred
for leaving LA and I'm kidding he
doesn't he doesn't care he just couldn't
make it but he said try to carry the
show so that people can see how much I'm
needed
so do you mean like cuz it's gonna be
pretty shitty without Rick [ __ ] on
me or anyone else in the vicinity which
he likes to do but we're gonna figure it
out this is exciting we have a very
special guest I don't know if you guys
are familiar this is the vice president
of the Comedy Store Erik Anderson guys
give him around the clock madam Garrett
Thank You Eleanor that's his first this
is first time on stage I believe but
yeah it's absolutely my first time on a
podcast it's first time on a podcast on
stage I'm gonna put can you hear him or
does he have to get I don't I always
push people closer like get I feel like
a you got the back aggressive oh I'm the
only one that gets my head pushed down
all right thanks guys
the only one in this room no Rachel got
it and wait yes that I don't know why I
sit in the mic eat the mic yeah a
well-trained and woman woman a great
woman and I love the Comedy Store and I
love that you're a part of a Comedy
Store
Erica's no how long have you been a part
of the Comedy Store now almost five
years
almost yeah over a little over four
years holy [ __ ] that goes fast yeah it's
like the blink of an eye yeah cuz when I
first met you it was that lucky strike
right I was the general manager of Lucky
Strike with all these titles there's a
Lucky Strike across the street right now
isn't really yeah we used to do stand-up
comedy a Lucky Strike on Hollywood
Boulevard and for people don't know
Lucky Strike is a bowling alley
yes but high-end bowling alley
experience so we had a room
where you would do stand-up comedy while
bowling is going on yes unbelievable
like you'd be in the middle of a punch
line or right about to get to the punch
line and you hear like a baby's birthday
party was going on our kids ridiculous
everybody's running around the noise
level was pretty intense yeah I was like
would you there were my favorite shows
were they pretty much it was I I don't
recall what night of the week it was but
I was surprised when it was Laura who
worked for me as a cocktail waitress
came and suggested it in this extra room
that we had could we do comedy in there
you know whatever night of the week and
all right
and it was a bit isn't it too loud care
don't care for nobody could hear them
comics I love pain yeah she was also a
waitress at the Comedy Store
hello how are you Laura was a waitress
at the Comedy Store and she was one of
my I'm gonna say top five worst
waitresses that ever worked for me she
was very funny beautiful girl she bought
me my favorite pair of slippers back
from Brazil what was she doing in Brazil
I let her go home over Christmas
vacation
she was very good let her go home
because she wasn't a good waitress is
right we didn't meet her wasn't there
and yeah I always make the Jews work on
Christmas that's fair right I always
done that yeah the club every Christmas
okay yeah yeah you know what's funny you
said his real name we call him eBay so
on the show is it out of me back no
that's much less Jewish
I think eBay then then yeah or in where
Adam came from Adam we've been playing
the Tempe improv right yeah we're here
we are in in Phoenix but this is
stand-up live he did Tempe right he did
the Tempe improv manager there and then
he came to the Comedy Store
what's this manager oh you're saying in
quote like Tempe he was a Tempe manager
no he's Tempe improv right it's a
goddamn improv that were this is yeah he
worked at the time
yeah which is like 20 minutes away there
you go what did you call it there you go
five light rail light rail stop that's
hard to say guy yeah
god you're [ __ ] tripping me up the
Rays writing in like right now see she
needs Rick but no it is a little further
from here but we're doing the podcast
doing shows there and at stand-up live
which is awesome yeah this whole
festival is fantastic I mean really what
a treat like a lot of things to do I
feel like really a part of something
yeah you are I guess all right so that's
good so we were doing the Lucky Strike
and now you're at the comedy stuff but
here's the thing like I don't know if
you know this the Comedy Store had a
really low hello we like to call the
dead years slash golden years because
when no one's watching we could have a
lot of fun uh-huh
so a lot of times like a lot of the
rooms were so dead and they'd be closed
and like you know one room would be
doing comedy the other one would just be
closing but no one really locked it up
so we would kind of play in that room
what's play we would play a lot of
things like hey you want to see what the
belly room looks like in the dark that
ain't fun did you know any the podcast
earlier today was with Nick Youssef and
Ari and Jason Tebow Oh were they part of
that anyway yes well so they were
discussing the weirdest or the oddest
place that they had ever had sex and
then it became the weirdest place that
they ever had sex in the comedy store
okay
it'll happen and all of them immediately
disclaim oh that that was before you
work there Eric yeah was dead years it
was the dead years you weren't there no
no no it was Dermot each time Mitsy was
still around but she wasn't coming in
and hanging out all night it was very
rare that she would come in and stay all
night long like she would come in to see
a showcase but she wouldn't like stay
till 2:00 3:00 in the morning when I
first started there she would write
she would like be there when you're
cleaning up and I'm like [ __ ] this
lady's always here eleanor was hired by
Mitzi yes and and was a close companion
of Mitzi's for a while too right yes I
was her personal assistant I worked
there for 12 years as a waitress but I
also did like a lot of odd jobs because
she everybody would quit or she would
fire them why would she fire Oh
so you gotta go or somebody had a hip
replacement they couldn't get up the
stairs anymore but he'd been with the
company for 17 years so he had to go and
fired but there was like things like
that or we had a town coordinator who
would drink a lot and he didn't come in
on Mondays and everybody would say oh he
called in sick it was something he ate
like he had a stomach virus so what
though why is it important for the
talent coordinator to be there on Monday
oh because all the comics call in it's
the busiest busy and say all the comics
call in for spots during the week right
so potluck and showcasing at this time
it was only on Sundays we only have Pop
mitzi have moved Monday no case it
originally was Monday night was potluck
night and then she moved it to Sunday
when Monday night football started
because it used to interrupt which was
weird because in California it kind of
ends early like 8:30 yeah right yeah so
but the potluck did start at 7:00 so she
switched it to Monday and I mean she
switched it to Sunday but then we were
so slow
it became Sunday and Monday then for a
while it was Sunday Monday and Tuesday
and number of times like when I was her
assistant like I mean we were like one
check away from like if she bounced the
check they would lose the club like it
was that bad it like we would always
have like like my mom says borrow from
Peter to pay Paul we would have the La
Jolla Long Beach La Jolla comedy store
would you know was making a lot of money
so they would pay for us or we have one
great joke Fat Tuesday really we sold so
much that night that that kind of kept
us going but it was a really dark dark
time like nearly closing people were
like Pauly
measuring for strip poles it was weird
like [ __ ] was happening he was like dude
right here right sound like the wheeze
dude you're gonna do it I can't wait see
you strip right you're still gonna work
here like nope I'm not gonna do this
ball but but when you got there you guys
made such an impact you and Adam
together I'm like I mean it's changed so
much now now like as a comic on cuz I've
only been doing sound a little over 10
years I'll walk in the original room or
the main room see how busy it is and I'm
like [ __ ] I can make more money as a
waitress tonight I get mad I'm like this
is [ __ ]
cuz i watch the waitresses and i'm like
they're moving too slow what the [ __ ] is
happening right now I could get 50
drinks to that table there no kidding no
of course I mean there but in my head
I'm like I can make so much money off
these people yeah and and that's weird I
should be like oh I should think about
the jokes I'm gonna tell but I'm like no
no I could make but you're probably
playing a full room though right
and you're part of that transition at
least part of that so how do you how did
you do that let me rephrase
well III was saying to somebody the
other day that the big change that that
we made was changing the vibe of the
club and when I got there it wasn't it's
like you're saying was very dark very
doing people were afraid to come yeah
exactly
and then comics were afraid to come by I
think that was really one of the big
things is that comics were afraid to
come to the Comedy Store which seemed
nonsense to me yeah and so we really
worked hard to change the vibe of the
club that it was more welcoming and open
and you know and that's that's made the
biggest difference I think and that you
know and then I'll you know honestly I
think Breton Biddle comme who does our
social media made a huge difference in
getting the word out that the club had
changed and that the vibe of the club
had changed yeah social media really
took a big divot and I think getting rid
of the and it's gonna sound harsh but we
[ __ ] on them all the time so we're you
guys really honest on this show
oh yeah not you again I'm guessing on
who it might be
but got rid of the old town coordinator
Eric got rid of him I hired him how
weird is that the beginning and end of
yeah what the Paul Tommy was the town
coordinator
oh he was buddy with Paulie yeah a
little bit he became that way but Tommy
was so good at talking to people like he
really did have a calming voice like he
was we needed a body to answer phones
and it was like are you justifying
hiring Tommy is that what's going on
right now in a way in a way I'm speaking
up for myself because no one's gonna
speak up for me but in a way it what
happened was we were so the hot we had
nobody working the phones it was
happened to be a weird busy time and we
were like we just need a body and read
Rob who was the manager I was like just
hire this guy and he's like who is he I
don't know he has a guitar he'll just
sit up there and he did he sat up there
for like 12 hours and just answered the
phone and played a stupid guitar and so
he playing his guitar doing all this
stupid [ __ ] and he admits he would call
and he would talk to her and calm her
down and that's how he got in with her
and then he finagled um Caen Trussell
was our other town coordinator and
Duncan was like I'm going on vacation
and I was like you're not coming back
all right
and he's like no not and he never did
and and then Tommy
Mitsy was like well let's put Tommy in
there he'll do it he used to call him
her cookie because he was so sweet a
little sweet cookie that was her thing
and then Eric came along was like Oh
Eleanor hired you I'm [ __ ] firing no
I don't think that's well yeah but you
just didn't fit in with the are the
visionary future for the comedy stars
everybody well you don't really fit in
with what we're doing here that's what
he would say to comics to scare them
please ask a random question
no no I don't think it's not that close
its proximity to the Comedy Store and
it's a very different sort of Club but I
and I'll tell you this the the ice house
is the oldest comedy club on the west
coast so and it's a great club it really
is yeah well okay remember how you said
Tempe like was far from here it's a
little even further than so it's like
it's good separation kinda and they they
also like you saying it's the oldest
club so they geared it like they would
have somewhat older comics doing like I
believe Leno used to it was that the
place he went oh no that I'm thinking of
the comedy man how many a magic club he
goes to that one which is also far away
and has been his podcast out of there
yeah it was called the Ice House
Chronicles yeah so I mean not to uh cut
you short but I want you to say are you
gonna stay with us well I would stay
Brody Brody Stephens join us if you guys
oh I'm sorry
woman to wait on Brody that was weird
a D'Amigo is the town coordinator so
he's one of the greatest he took over
Tommy he's one of the greatest guys in
the world and I have to say that because
you want to write so yeah he's terrific
a smart guy good-looking you left off
okay so good luck big penis right guys
yeah speaking of big penis we're gonna
the terrible segue Brody terrible thing
it's it's average thank you average
Brody I would say Stephen Brody Stephens
lately
Brody perhaps a little Stevie
now Brody's in Arizona
what's a college sure went to college so
he's ferret bet Arizona State you got it
you got it
are they lost that they lose are they
losing to USC right now okay quiet okay
we're not talking about it I get it I
get it
and it's so Brody you were there a store
yeah
Comedy Store I passed I'm here right now
yes you got it true and you have done
the Comedy Store podcast before I
believe we got interrupted by nice phone
calls if you're gonna get interrupted
have it be dice that's Andrew Dice Clay
I was honored never heard of him I like
this guy all right that's a guy can do
audience miked up no okay no but we'll
have him yell it out if we need I would
say yell or don't interact I mean over
there you go
you don't me bro daily the child mic for
the audience all right here we go here
we go here I'd and yeah Arizona and it's
a comedy festival right festival has
been really yeah organized good vibe
laid-back professional good food hotels
nice the restaurants nice the little
pop-up studio was cool it's great and
it's good I was mentioning on one of the
videos you're doing how so it's really
it's organized festival you do a lot of
comedy festivals and they're not
organized or they're making excuses and
this and that this thing get the shuttle
vans on time you got everything
everything going nice little sponsorship
it's a and it's tonight's five so it's a
good time that's gonna be the word of
the podcast vibes yeah the vibe of the
Comedy Store that the vibe changed when
technically they got rid of Tommy but
also when Eric Eric and Adam just took
it over the Comedy Store I mean he added
was doing the booking and stuff but Eric
was doing the shape of the club the
actual business of the club which is not
an easy thing and then lifting that vibe
black cloud if you will I hate to say we
lifted the black off the black building
but you know what I mean like it's just
it did
become a different place don't you think
I'm a different place but a better vibe
I'm more positive yeah I mean me I I've
been performing there since like 2000 I
got past so at a beer I normally don't
drink but hey that's how good this
festival is that it cause cause you do
some shots no need to do that if we have
another show later so I'm a little Amen
little tipsy so great the show would be
I could use a water actually it's good
there is barking orders at the crowd
that's not miked yeah I either dry mouth
once or on the show so that's awesome
The Comedy Store yes the vibe change I
think was a combination yeah people
don't realize that Eric came in there
like he's a like a fixer he's like the
you know the bar rescue guy just came at
know he came man it was like though just
perfect professional you know friendly
but business and you know got stuff done
and then you know got guys talk you
could talk to a you know some of the
door guys they know what's going on I
talked the door guys
I talked the waitresses but I would like
talk to the door guys and you know they
know and Eric's a big part of it I'm not
just saying that Adam II get from the
Tempe improv like just talking to Adam
grew up in the valley with me I've known
Adam since this childhood were you guys
bar Mitzvahed together
well I wasn't Bar Mitzvah but he grew up
with Brazil oh you know Mike Brucella
yeah after the Cubs his family grew up
with Brazil oh that's awesome
so Adam went to Joe Torre baseball camp
out in Encino as a kid so I've known
Adam I don't what was your part in the
Joe Torre baseball club yeah I was a
camper and then later on I graduated to
being able to drive the kids home you
know camp driver and then I there's been
no accusations in that right so yes Eric
Adam I also feel that the you know Rogen
coming back
getting them to feel safe to come back
to this kind of shitty environment I
mean for me I I wrote about me I guess I
was like when I got there was it wasn't
it was telling somebody was like it was
intimidating it was a scare was a scary
place to go yeah and then I would have
my late-night spots and I was around the
I was I kind of wrote above the
craziness to be honest I saw it but
maybe I just got used to it's a comedy
story you're used to crazy to craziness
chairs being thrown fighting somebody
throws chairs it was it was it was loose
like I would say now God the the
comedian's kind of police the place but
back then it was more like they ran the
place and I don't feel like I feel like
it's a nice mix now like comedians could
do it they want but there's somebody
who's like closing up shop and we know
when that room like a green room area or
but like people respect that whereas
before they would push it a little bit
absolutely
and I feel like before of course the
inmates used to run the asylum and
that's because like going back to what
you were saying with Mitzi not being
around all night or only coming in at a
certain maybe two days a week she wasn't
there
no but there was no fear like the foot
when I first started she would show up
we would all be like Oh Mitzi's here
background action everybody moved do
something yeah you don't want to know
whoa tagging do something you know
everybody move because that's how she
was but now it's like they I feel like
it's come back because people are like
oh [ __ ] Eric's here you're like yeah
like in a good way don't like them we
gotta be working like that but the
problem is are you saying from like
comedian point of view or because you
wait your waitress wait you're saying
for them okay
yeah that but if you can keep this thing
that explains it and order if you can
keep the staff organized well and
everything else kind of falls into I
mean that's another thing the the girls
and the guys and everybody it is like a
finely tuned rock and roll machine back
there
and they're in there haven't and they're
not it's good energy they're not and
that's the other thing that's going back
to the box there and they enjoy
hopefully they enjoy their work and
they're having a great time and that to
me is important in any establishment
that you run that's that's a
service-oriented establishment that the
staff likes what they're doing and where
they're at and then the your guests will
pick up on that vibe you'll feel like if
you go into a place where you know that
the management is mean to the staff and
the staff feels beaten down something
that you pick up on that vibe right away
I think and I think now when you come
into the Comedy Store the staff is happy
you know the place is busy you know
people are making money like so you do
that the phenomenal late-night you know
show in the main room and you do it in
front of an audience you know like where
I I'd say you know when I first got
there around one o'clock there wasn't
anybody left in that room in any of the
rooms really I mean it was like four or
five comics left and then whoever was
the end of the line I've got to go on in
front of those four or five comics for
as long as they wanted to go on but now
you come to the end of our shows excuse
me
and there's an audience to play for yeah
and maybe it's you know maybe one night
it's 15 people but one some nights maybe
14 yeah you know so until closing yes
sometimes 100 people yeah so I I think
that's a different vibe where you know
the staff can you know is working in a
busy room where they have the potential
to make you know really great money all
night long and but the the comics can
come in at any you can have almost any
spot on the show and you're gonna play
to a good audience and I think that
makes a whole big difference yeah I mean
I do that main room on Fridays and
Saturdays I'm going on it you know 12:45
sometimes and I've always have fun never
and it could be yeah it's never like
yeah sometimes it's less than others but
it's always good you get the belly room
now going on it's just you think I think
I did it the main room a couple weeks
ago and there had to be 150 people in
there at that late hour
right before you there I was like this
is great because this is also not only
the vibe but then they're saying to see
Brody like there Brody fans are like all
the [ __ ] we you're getting you get a
following with that show Terry's you
know they everybody knows that you're
gonna close the show and it becomes your
spa
and people are turning up even later for
the show just to see your portsmen to
the lights
I bring ya I love doing it but you know
I'm not I'm not you know we talk about
other clubs and I was thinking about how
wide the Comedy Store is is the way it
is because I'm not going to name these
clubs but for a club but I calling for I
do my veil it's okay to play out there
it's me it's the way it is you yeah
you're you're all professionals and
you're all out to perform right so we're
not feeling some loyalty you know there
is human element involved but we're only
putting most comics on for 15 minutes to
20 minutes so there's a lot of night
left ahead of you
exactly so I have no expectation that
you're only coming to the Commons oh
okay
I've never had that ever know that some
of the other clubs there they're
corporate to corporate meaning for well
personally what happened was I can think
of a specific thing you put in the veils
you there this one particular place
you're putting them in like it's a new
system and it's like three weeks of
advanced oh yeah three weeks advanced
then you get an email confirmation and
then you have to email back ASAP and if
you don't you don't get a spot the spot
goes away so it's like just negative
energy you're reading negative yeah I
don't like ASAP in any email that always
makes actually just annoys me yeah
that's that was anybody who ever hears
this podcast is gonna probably send me
all the emails yeah I know
it made it and made me you know
appreciate the Comedy Store and then I
mean beyond that it went to like me
having to shift something around and I
got another email like well you can do
this but you can't and it's like inmates
then you go look at the Comedy Store you
go you'd call in or tell your veils or
text them in whatever Mondays and then
they call you back or text you back and
then you show up you don't have to like
let the club know I'll be there
and if you don't make those is like it
you just you treat each other with
respect and then if you have to fun but
hate it it made it me this club like it
was just I could see why like why that
particular club is not what it is
because they're not the comedian's yeah
you want to be like have the comedian's
being so yeah it comes back to the
comedian's it comes back to what are you
saying like make it in a fun environment
like I was teasing saying like that the
girls are like oh no Eric's here but
what I'm saying what I mean is is that
it's an authoritative presence it's not
a mean presence it's like okay
we're a real baby a little bit of that
and I mean but I'm not super me no no
that's what Elinor seen as well start by
hitting you would you also air you don't
try to be I mean you're good sense of
humor but you don't you let the
comedians you don't you know eat them
but you also don't like take their
energy away I'm not saying yes some
people will do that some people I'm not
naming names anywhere anywhere I'll need
names waiters like but there's sometimes
employees or even comedians they'll kind
of like you're getting right you kind of
like have a feel for comedians like you
understand their space and it when to
talk to when not to how to you know I
pick up on that with you well I I
honestly try to treat everybody at the
club the same I don't matter that your
level of you know I mean I try to beat
everybody with respect and you know be
professional and you know and you know
some of them I know better than other
ones and maybe I joke around with them
but I try to be respectful of all of the
comics in the same way so that it
doesn't seem like I'm like oh it's and I
think for me that that were it's not
genuine that works but exactly that's my
nothing's genuine and what I genuinely
like the comic I mean I genuinely like
my job and I like all the people that
are there and and the big the big
difference that I saw that we needed to
do was to make the club welcoming to
comics which is what I didn't think we
were I thought it was really I thought
it was exclusive and to some people yeah
when I first got there and I was like
why why does certain comics never come
here
like I mean like didn't ya a Greg
Fitzsimmons man Phil yes maybe I'm gonna
say 8 obviously 10 years ago 10 years
ago and he was at Fox Sports doing a
pilot thing and I was the warm-up guy
and I mentioned ice his ode I still stay
still performs ago yeah he goes up the
comedy store that's still going on like
diving with Seinfeld said that but that
was 10 years ago I'm thinking like now
The Comedy Store is the number one spot
and dice of course everyone knows
Seinfeld came last year in performance
yeah it did and he complained about how
me mitts he was him the whole time which
is all which is awesome because she was
very honest and she did pass him she
made him I paid regular but then she
didn't see where he fit in it never his
comedy never he never got it yeah
which is fine and she always told me oh
he's just awful and I'm sorry jack she's
told me some crazy [ __ ] but I can't say
all of it but but that one I remember
like her being like yeah he just didn't
work for us and I was like wow it's
Seinfeld he had them oh really show yeah
it was in New York I he had a fight he
had to earn his own shoes when he bought
a house down the street from MIT see
after he became successful oh he did
fight her
I I don't know whether it was despite
her that's where he bought a house it
doesn't bother her because she wouldn't
even notice I want a fire because this
is a this is a you know comedy store
podcast I want to want people to know
like my history yes oh no I feel but I
you know I grew up in the valley grew up
in the San Fran ovale my name a 180 a
guy and my mom dated Jack who lived on
Holloway over there on alta loma' so
this is like in the 80s so in the 80s
and he had a patio I could always see
the comedy store the lights of the
comedy store it is this this is in the
80s so I always would see the guy ever
knew about it but it's like a
long-distance relationship yeah I just
remember the flashing lights and the I
could see it from there and when I first
did comedy tried it was back in 93 I
took a workshop at UCLA and it was Pauly
Shore sister ran it and I took it
specifically a middle name because I get
up because it was the Comedy Store I
don't know that I felt like I had a
connection with the Comedy Store and I
saw that Mitzi
I mean sandy was teaching that course so
I felt like I'm gonna learn this Comedy
Store I felt connected with it I had a
Comedy Store binder so yeah and we would
take her class yeah I still but I'll
tell you what I did though we'd do the
class over UCLA Tuesday night do like
two minutes and then after the class
always drive by the Comedy Store this is
1990 yet 1993 I was there you were there
okay yeah drive by the Comedy Store and
I go like whining Andrew Dice Clay wait
a minute wait anyway go ahead but I
would drive by and I go yeah one day
maybe I mean one day and then we had our
graduating class there I got to perform
right there in the original room at
night yeah Bri that was my first time
and I mean I so when I you know I
consider myself a comedy store comedian
for in my various what I do I mean I'm
at the prime time I can play I could do
it all I could play all the difference
we know that wise but I'm just loyal to
it I don't i i'm not a bandwagon comedy
store guy so I take pride you know what
I mean I was there
you made you arms bad before yeah late
night and you know Tommy
to be honest always gave me a couple
spots a week which was nice and he says
you know if you're in town you got a
Friday Saturday you know oh he's got one
on like after the hump which was fine
and I'd like lead into Don Barris but
yet Tommy was good with that but I never
had main room spots never ever anything
in there in that interesting give me
with Tommy I never until the very end
because maybe five six years ago I was
gonna go do La Jolla and he said because
you're gonna do a longer set why don't
you go up in the main room at the end
and
and do like 30 minutes and work on the
hour for yeah well yet to do la jolla
so I did it and then I ended up doing La
Jolla and then Tommy kept giving me that
late-night spot so I said okay I'll keep
doing it and doing it and then I flash
it out to the point where I take my
special which is in who knows what's
gonna happen with that see so went away
but and I'll still continue but yeah
Tommy like he gave me that that spot for
to get ready for La Jolla and I just
kind of kept doing it yeah and you owned
it yeah thank God me and you build
something out it's great how many stores
late-night Brody does yeah he just said
he's the last act on and he does an hour
sometimes sometimes more I come and take
a temperature of the room right some
around the hour mark and then we go from
there right yeah it's the late-night
thing it's you got to read the audience
because you don't want to keep them
against their will exactly you got to
read them and also not give them stiff
they don't want to see stick what
they've seen everything and they don't
want to be berated either yeah you got
to be kind it's a very interactive show
too I mean you've built it you've made
it your own yeah you know and I think a
lot of people turn up just for it when
they know that you're on the late-night
spot yeah I appreciate it I have fun
with it yeah you've read it sometimes
they want joke sometimes they want a
little I'll interact with the comedians
and then sometimes yeah it's just yeah
I'm just lucky I have it I keep doing it
and you know but I'm not gonna I always
have fun doing it and you know so I'm
not there this weekend who knows you
know maybe I'll be well it may be
somebody new fantastic is taking over
this way to never know don't do that you
might leave now
but specifically for this podcast then
you're here Erica I just want to say
like you know say that yeah The Comedy
Store is real like foundation and it is
nice to see you know everyone doin their
thing I just hope it continues no
absolute like when I see Brody I think
him his family and now think of us
family but it was he really was I
remember Brody from the graduation class
- coming back - getting passed - just
mmm you know really doing the grind and
yeah
Stephen Brody Stephens you got an
switched Nate whatever you want to do
it's you're good at it yeah those
original room spots you know those work
it's a brutal you so watch I'd be
picking up my drinks like oh how does he
do they were hard it was a dog because
as a waitress I was watching the comics
like the [ __ ] are they doing you know
there's six people in here and most of
them are like you know pissed off or
drunk or they pissed off their date and
their date left so they're like I'll sit
watch this [ __ ] guy you know and
there's - yeah and you get them to come
around so that was inspiring to me no
thanks like I never wanted to be a comic
at that point but I was like wow like
and now I get to do it late night yeah
I'm learning I'm in the grind like you
were yeah it was uh I was never like
scared doing that room I bet it was you
had to be you have to be like on your
game but back then I remember it would
be like dark or that room was darker if
you I took her
like wise or just darker vibe while all
of it like all right like it was darker
which made it a little more I mean you
can turn the lights down anyway but I'm
saying overall it was it's better maybe
I would turn no I know like that it felt
like that all the time
yeah not because of Holtzman's comedy
I'm just saying to my finger again he
likes a spot like the rooms darkened
yeah but like in the main room me
personally I'm it's like those are like
that's a lot of that's like an incubator
you're like that's a lot right yeah but
that original room it was hard but then
you got like somehow literally like
something you're like reaching out for
like of somebody to help you so you hear
a voice like let me throw me something
where's now you can kind of see people a
little more oh you over there it's a
little more plus the mood is a little
lighter but now it's a lot lighter but I
mean but back then it was still like
that kind of dreary but even Sunset
Strip it went through oh yeah
energy and then come in you know the you
know House of Blues getting that vibe
whatever concert was going on across the
street do you remember when they built
the house of blues or no I came here
like right about when that was happening
were you there before when busy on the
oh no no I wasn't there when she owned
the place across the street right but
the the little saloon she called it have
a shirt though yes and she gave me a lot
of weird merchandise that nobody else
has and anyway so she when they were
building the House of Blues we in the
original room there's a giant front
window you can see it as a glass window
you can see out of it have some names
written on it a number of people have
asked me what you know why we don't get
rid of that window oh yeah those people
I love Y and Oh too bad
well I so my feeling is making sure put
that window in yeah like what Who am I
to say get rid of the window right she
wanted me when they get I will fight
them all off I made a conscious effort
knocked it thank you I like the window
because it feels like that's what she
wanted like you walk by and you get to
see them even though you can't really
see them if you're walking the window
pleaser I don't know we're not going
anywhere
yeah well we did that because we do
earlier shows like it's so amazing and
then also but when they were building a
House of Blues
I remember when Mitzi was sitting in the
in the original room in the bucket seats
on the side not the ones in the back she
was sitting and she was looking out the
window and I was like oh what is she
doing like in the booth she was sitting
now bucket seats and she's looking out
the window and I walked in i was like is
everything okay and she's like no and
she was smoking a cigarette and I'm like
okay anything I can do like is he
nervous you know you're on edge because
she fire you for nothing you say you had
to be careful and I was like um anything
I can do for you and she was like yeah
tell him the stop building this [ __ ]
building I was like I can't I don't I
can't tell them you want me to go across
the street and there's all this
construction happening she goes they're
gonna [ __ ] up my view and I was like why
would you want people looking out was
everything it was nothing
oh really you get you the whole I love
how you could see them beautiful now
right cuz they knock down the House of
Blues and so at that moment I was so
young and I was just like okay you know
and I just walked out on my case she
wants them to stop [ __ ] working
across the street and they were like
don't listen to her I'm like okay and
then the House of Blues went up and I
didn't pay attention until they knocked
it down this year yeah yeah view is
spectacular you can see feel awful you
should come back like this is crazy
good comeback and just sit here cuz it's
so beautiful but that's gonna be
something they're building on yeah it's
gonna be a very large building probably
as tall as the Mondrian you know are you
nervous that that may change the vibe or
no no I would help hotels help us well
yeah I think hotels help I think the
added traffic the foot traffic on the
street will help and I think right now
other businesses being on Sunset would
help we're really the only club in our
little area our section of the strip
worth Brit for entertainment then you
have to go like two miles down the road
to get to maybe one mile down the road
but to get to the whiskey and the
rainbow and all of that there's just
aren't that many clubs left on Sunset
Boulevard so I think it's great when Sun
sets a destination and I think we all
benefit on sunset from from it being a
destination so the more things that are
there so you're coming and you're going
to something else and you're like oh I
forgot about the Comedy Store and then
people remember and then they the next
time they plan a trip to us or they look
us up online but I mean are you I mean
what I mean what could be across the
street maybe it's a crazy noise maybe
how they make the valet well I used to
have to go to the meetings in West
Hollywood Monroe start it with the
taxing on it right really high taxing
and hurt the Comedy Store tax was
enormous ly higher than a lot of the
others right and we were like what why
we don't have a saddle ranch has fights
outta you need security for saddle ranch
House of Blues has fight things like
that we don't even have fight we're just
a friggin comedy club and they were like
yeah we you we they just didn't they
said we made the most noise they said
that the crowd on the front like hanging
out on the patio bar was always loud
leaving there they were
they park in the hills are loud I don't
know if it was the staff or the actual
but you never know the residents
complaining or so they park behind that
right now we would all walk up as a
group and be loud and so we were like
what the [ __ ] we're loud but that's what
they said in West Hollywood happy that
we're still there yeah because there's
just nothing else I mean there's no
other clubs near us
he loved the Comedy Store though ya know
they're great to us the city was
Hollywood's great to it and they've
always been it was just that we didn't
understand how why the tax was so high
they're very nice they're always very
cool with us and that but they were
adding security because there was so
many stupid fights and stuff so the
taxes went up and then we went to find
out why and never lived until you seen
the mayor of West Hollywood joy and oh
my god he was so funny
he's so flamboyant I think he was
wearing short shorts I was like okay
this can't be real Oh am Reno 911 won
like it was that elaborate and we were
he just came in for a meeting I was like
he don't even have a suit on like it's
amazing he's just wearing a tank top so
it's like a real deal the West Hollywood
oh yeah and I like it you know it's not
real dude there's not that way anymore
whatever it is now I'm just saying like
it was funny when we met with him we
were like happening but he what they
were honest I mean they said we were the
loudest so that's why but now it's come
full circle and everybody is excited
yeah that were that we're putting the
foot traffic there but when that when
that when that new hotel across the
street comes up maybe that's gonna
affect the sound it's gonna bounce back
you know like goes out going down sends
a positive energy across the city it
really does I mean what do you think I
think the only thing I would have our
positive energy bouncing back to us
there you go
the only thing I don't like is oh it's a
positive side batters [ __ ] the only
thing I don't like about Sunset Strip
are you gonna say the town needs start
you know what I don't like about how
mister that's what I really need to know
actually I can tell you
what about it really I don't need to
think about it I just you know several
people a week do really what they don't
like really if I had to think about it
I'd probably maybe have one or two would
you really are you kidding me no I'm
kidding
no the window people are quite like you
way about I don't strip I don't like the
sometimes it's cars are speeding a
little much these days
well the in general anyway but there's a
lot of a lot of Armenian Persian racing
you know it's like Beverly Hills versus
like racing on the racing well that's
what they're doing it's their race I
mean like I know I see there I see where
they're coming from Beverly Hills are
the Persian guys did they make it to the
Laugh Factory it's like extended play
like when you're playing pole position
I'm telling you that's what it is I mean
obviously you you have you've given to
this some thought
yeah I'm there every night I wanted a
speed bye
that's my only complaint is okay so they
the speedy I don't know you know that
has nothing to do with the Comedy Store
though that's the actual Sunset Strip
and nobody can control that like I can't
send Erik out there in like a neon top
and slow that traffic down
maybe Haman Holtzman that would work
they could horsemen could get so didn't
they used to chase Robert ever via out
into traffic I guess that was to slow it
down right no that really upset me when
they did that but yeah like there was a
comic if you don't know this guy he's
been at the some people talk about on
the podcast a lot of people have asked
me to have him on the podcast oh you
should I would love to have Robert
William and provide on the podcast but
we're gonna have to do it in an open
arena because that scent is not oh so
you know for people who don't know so
Robert a perv is a stand-up comic he's
been at the Comedy Store for a very long
time he's 20 years more than that 25
years yeah he is he established himself
as the closing act of potluck on Mondays
oh just like me it might be 35 years I'm
gonna be on the baby because like Robin
Williams when he came in right he had a
flashback
it was a [ __ ] back guys
here he freaked out and then but he
wears the same green suit he was a green
suit he got a new one no didn't they
update it right but he wears tin foil
underneath it it's not those plastic
because the radio waves sometimes affect
his body yes it does makes no sense to
him he's a paranoid schizophrenic
but he also has a lawyer and then he
snapped and then Mitty felt bad for him
because she loved his jokes prior to
that which he still does
ish ghosts make Carson it was all
positive Carson Carson jokes and then
she when he snapped she used to give him
bus money so he can get to him from the
comedy store to close out thee what
caused him to snap and Don Barris see
neither of you thought now that's not
true
neither of us were negating that in any
way shape or form however I think it did
happen a little bit before so to dawn
and then Don just how do you say went
with it right well when I when I got to
the store there was a whole act where he
would go on and everybody there'd be a
group of comics in the room that would
make noises while he was performing and
then he would run or what they would
chase him and then he would run away and
we go and then traffic he would run into
the Sunset Boulevard with the microphone
with the microphone take the microphone
and he'd run out and he'd be inside
maybe still doing his act I don't know
comes would be bond right dangerous
right or an Armenian right it's crazy so
that happened they chased him out there
and the debt doesn't go on as much
anymore now not matter
there's no chasing him out into the
street I got mad when he went into
traffic I was like guys it's one thing
if you want to [ __ ] with okay fine
you're he's got an act that you and I
first you think you know they're [ __ ]
with this guy and this is fasting and
wrong sit go when he shows up every week
so he's yeah he's in on the hand on it
for he enjoys the attention right he
enjoys the light that that like coming
to the store hey Robert everybody's late
and I didn't like you I don't know what
I did nothing you don't remember him
somebody away Nazi sympathiser because
he calls everybody that that's that what
he still says that about you're not
using well yeah because that's why this
but dombarris is very German looking and
even Mitzi used to call him the Aryan
dog yeah and uh so Robert picked up on
that and he's like this Nazi because Dom
would pick on him he called him a Nazi
and anybody in Don's gang is part of the
Nazi don't do we don't call them again
I'm sorry okay you're right Group group
of gentlemen and one lady yes and that
they you know do this thing they play
and every time Robert goes onstage it's
a whole thing they throw thing whatever
but if you ever shined a light near him
I thought that was on there everybody
we've had laser pointers yeah of course
he felt that that was burning through
his head and so he would scream and this
is an interesting thing that happened
you know this all me to stuff coming out
to take everybody okay that's been on me
too and it never does so meat comes out
and everybody's like writing all these
things and people are nervous like
everybody's on edge it's the whole thing
and I met the Comedy Store I'm about
waiting to go on on a Monday night it's
kind of late and Robert William my
provider comes up in his green suit but
he's missing the jacket and the shirt
now cuz it's very hot in LA so he's got
shirtless but he got the green slacks on
and he's like uh Eleanor and he's
holding a suit in his hand cuz he might
have to put it back on Eleanor I have to
apologize for you to you I I may have
grabbed you inappropriately in 1998 I'm
like what I'm like dude you just go back
to 98 and he goes and you yelled at me
and you said don't touch me and I was
like okay because I was probably waiting
tables and I'm surprised I didn't hit
you with a tray and so he was like and
you told me you know
don't touch me and I just wanted to
apologize and say I was inappropriate
but I want to say they were hitting me
with laser tags and that or laser light
yeah later
and that broke through and that's what
MIT is messing with my brain and that's
why I did it
I go did you just me to me with a
[ __ ] excuse
did you just come at me you assaulted
them that I assaulted it when he
assaulted you because he was immediately
took the man's side Wow he touched me I
don't even remember it which I probably
should remember you should remember so
you are the time for the Commodore that
you're now immune to it probably that or
you feel like you kind of share apart
like you brought it on should have said
some cuz I should have I was wearing
tight clothing you should have said I
sure was asking is it the same outfit
you have on right now this isn't a
touchable it's not too late to like get
them this is the attitude towards
progress that gets everyone in trouble
right so we can go get him like me and
appropriately want once whoa that's a
key news great news now and then I
grabbed him by his throat and pinned him
against the wall breaking news Eleonora
tests all day but that one I remember
the end of his career so it's a wash and
it's not because he was black I just
remember it that's all like it was
Robert I don't remember I don't he's
always nice but yeah I just
Eddie was really oddly inappropriate and
never have been that way and then but
that was the only time you were violent
I am very violent Dave Tyree smacked me
in the end it's a long story
so usually you've naming names this is
our this is my new yeah that's right
everyone that's I'm unfortunate some
people said that about Eleanor I'm gonna
be with you for these moments
oh is this a sympathetic male feminist
are you trying to get laid
I'm Anna's asking a question yeah
whatever you need are you here for you
I'm here going on here lri I have your
back I'll go with you to small claims
court I'll give you my little zoom a
promo code anything help you bring
charges up against a purveyor or whoever
or Eddy I mean it is crazy Adam Sandler
today is getting in trouble for like
touching a girl's I'm kidding I'm not
kidding whoa that's oh that's even
Sandler it's like it's a view watch it
he's just like touches the girl's leg
but with this tongue winner freaking
down like ha that's the only time well
here this is a thing that happened for
some reason at the Comedy Store
somebody must have came in and we had a
meeting during the dark ages and they
were saying we need to have a sexual
harassment conversation with the staff
yeah now god I don't know how this
happened but they got us all in the
kitchen and at the time like your door
guys were like Bobby Lee you know I mean
was a mess like Bob Oh Shaq Freddy so
like we were all in the kitchen and
somebody's giving a speech one of the
managers was reading the pamphlet of
like what you can and can't do and we're
all looking at each other like we
already did all this so what do we do
yeah like um he gave her herpes so what
what is that is this on the list like we
were just [ __ ] around of course and
so the guy the poor manager who just had
to do it because that's what they make
you do he you know we're all sitting
there and there's about 20 of us in the
kitchen area and I'm leaning on this
like where we keep our computers and
stuff and I'm just leaning on this desk
like hurry the [ __ ] up I got to get
ready to start working and I'm as I'm
like leaning over this comic came in
Dave Tyree who I absolutely adore and he
smacked me so hard in the ass cuz I was
sticking my ass out and it echoed
through the whole meeting and I just
stood up I go I'm gonna say this
meetings over like that was it like what
are you good this is where we work guys
get on board or don't I know Brody is
right now looking at me like small
claims court we're going to the big it
make some money off this this let's take
that guy you are naming names you're
going right down I don't care he's great
guys are that's how the Comedy Store is
you're not calm Easter is not that way
vice president oh my god
none of that happens at the Comedy Store
we need to put our just a lot of beeping
I'm a safe place
where's all romanís yeah you would mess
this up for sure so yeah I mean the
comedy star has been an amazing roller
coaster and it's fun that I mean it's
not funny they were actually is real
sexual harassment and suits and things
people inappropriate but we work in an
appropriate in an inappropriate
appropriate building Wow it's an
inappropriate business I mean you're
stand-up comic right you're always
trying to take you know every level or
most of it is goofing yeah none of it
but if it was ever serious like I said
that one time when it was serious with
Eddie I got physical and then he got and
then he immediately apologized like he
was like I don't even know what the [ __ ]
I was thinking like immediately like and
we've been friends ever said I would
never be like oh he if somebody crossed
the line really crossed the line I you
call him out we're pretty clear with the
waitstaff AB you know what we think you
know if anybody's feel super
uncomfortable to come to it what the
minute you leave we all have orgies
there's a dry there's a dress code and
the girls can have tattoos right they
have that leather up okay it's true you
can get tattoos in the bedskirt the
girls that you see with the tattoos they
don't actually work there what the girls
with the tattoos they don't actually
work there that's them right there we
trades of drinks what system do you guys
use for the O's it's whirl
guess again micros no that's all I know
oh there's only one more tool Oh ha
Aloha yes
oh that's from Hawaii very good that's
what Obama donated them yeah oh no
work too long too long Oh half the time
why do you feel like it doesn't work is
there you did you experience some type
of problem with that
never okay but no I don't I say always I
know I was a waiter you know I used to
work at Red Robin good where you really
heard that yeah I waited focus also
that's great I was probably gonna go
this was back in two weeks ago thanks
Sheriff
but things working out now no vice
president oh no I do a joke I have two
other jobs I work at Dave & Buster's
guys we're doing bits now ready for the
11:45 that's a great waited tables at
Red Robin is that the endless fries I
love fry refills if they're down that's
my table I don't know if you girls fight
over the tables by Eleanor did em I'm
still fighting them
that's my only happy because when you
work there there was only four tables
for you that you'll never have oh yeah
by the way because he's gone anyway uh
we had Richard Pryor for one year every
Wednesday night really jam-packed in the
original room do you remember that I
don't think I was around Richard Pryor
came back he started doing Monday
Wednesdays and Fridays that was the
busiest I'd ever seen until now newish
but this was even crazy busier because
it would be like Whoopi Goldberg Chevy
Chase people were sitting in the aisles
like where the walkways so we would have
to step over people to serve drinks
Richard called me a [ __ ] from stage oh
wait he must must have known you more
but his wife wouldn't let me give him
alcohol so I it was water yeah like he
asked for a toonie which is martini
and I gave it to him but it was water
and he drank it and he was like [ __ ] so
they would all come to see Richard Pryor
and would it was he doing his new bats
old [ __ ] did was it him not sad was it
funny it was a little bit of both it was
a little mix of both because sometimes
chew
had to carry him onstage so he was in
the wheelchair at that point and Jen
would take him and his wife I think she
was number four and number eight anyway
he has a lot of wives and she would
bring him in we truly would carry him on
stage set him on a stool and he really
would just somewhat riff I mean it was
insane like oh my god it was amazing
yeah tell you what his life was like
like whatever it was no no whatever this
day was all this David almost like
clearing like telling you like um you
know what his therapy was like that day
the nurse this [ __ ] that [ __ ] you know
everybody was it was very funny you know
and then he would [ __ ] on Jen because
she used to hit him a lot in the
original room on a Monday so he'd fallen
away no no but you're saying it was his
show you knew he was coming in yeah it
was Richard show is Monday Wednesday and
Friday
three nights and then he only came down
to Wednesdays because it was so hard to
come Monday Wednesday Karlin used to the
main room all the time always runs like
we had George for eight nights I think
we had Jackie Mason well night that was
incredible remember that it was
incredible in that it was so packed and
this was Mitzi trying to salvage you
know calling in an old favor right yeah
Tony click yes music Hoffman Tony
Clifton mm-hmm we had that did you have
the Andy Kaufman Tony Clifton Oranje
have yes Bob Bob zmuda right yeah they
had a wrestling match of the main room
they put a rush oh I heard about that
but Jackie Mason we would get like four
between 405 and 4 for 10 people in that
main room and that's not what it seats
I'm not saying with it okay but we would
have the fire marshal show up and I'd be
like hi you guys should come back here
because it was so hard to get through
the main room yeah serving teas to old
Jews from Beverly Hills amazing Jackie
Mason he would pack it in there packed
he did 12 nights straight and he was
amazing
he was brilliant so yeah I mean so nice
so nice so funny yeah Robin Williams
Robin Williams did some shows Martin
Lawrence did his community service there
I mean he's certainly losing his mind in
the middle of the street on Ventura
Boulevard absolutely right absolutely
right he was waving a gun and his
community service was to give back so he
did a show for them and he did it at the
Comedy Store it was packed so there were
some like cool moments back Danny stores
always like yeah because it had such a
history it was just going through a low
itself because those comics that came up
were on the road or became superstars or
you know what yeah for a while mitts
used to try to get us like when we'd
sign when she put a new pay regular to
sign something to say they would perform
at the store two times a year if they
were giant celebrities but I also want
to say not only that the management the
comedians but the social media yeah we
already gave little call you did shout
out yeah we didn't want to do it in
front of them because you see the other
clubs do it and it's not organic it's
forced in the comics or social media it
seems to be fairly like nice and honor
so I when I got to the club anyone
threatened took over the social media a
comic had come to me and he said look
you know I don't know what you guys are
doing for social media he goes but I'll
tell you before you got here there was
no social media like I never saw The
Comedy Store ever on social media like I
didn't see anything about them so now I
get up in the morning I check my all my
different social media he said and I
feel like I missed out on a party yeah I
felt like there's something going on and
I wasn't there what was I thinking yeah
you made a mess yeah and now I think
that's a daily thing and I think that's
obviously because of Britain with other
clubs I've noticed are doing they're
just mirroring one another like that
sometimes I'll see you I could see yeah
I'll see an admin I'll be like those of
you sitting here Breton is wearing the
teal t-shirt over is the gorilla coming
in really coming in oh hey there we're
in a we're in a storefront
there's a big gorilla in the window you
can't ignore the gorilla in the room
wasn't that the same he's gone right we
lost them do we have to wrap it up but
we have a okay we can wrap it up because
we gotta get ready to do I'm talking to
you anyway I got it across the street
and do the show we're gonna go do so
you're gonna do the Brody show stand-up
comedy we're gonna have Brody's gonna
close it out he's gonna do like an hour
and a half maybe two hours tonight I'm
doing a short set you don't want to do a
lot to bring the lights down here I'm on
vacation okay
I'm in a six minute you know you're
compressing your entire act into six
minutes you're only doing six minutes of
your act
six minutes 6 minutes dougie fresh room
you're on it's been a great pod great
podcast festival yes this is an amazing
our last podcast are we the last of the
festival oh you closed it with The
Comedy Store up I got here all right
calm down
closing words Wow is that that's
interesting
I don't do coke after this yeah and I
did the first one today mm audience
warm-ups and then I did the first
podcast today here and I do the last one
it's like a lot of connections so many
connections Brodie and they're all
positive connections you got it would
you say a lot of energy energy matters
all right Eric Anderson thank you so
much Brodie Steven thank you for jumping
in asthmatic sidekick I appreciate it
thanks all things comedy yes
comedy short love you
[Applause]